citizens of the reject nation we've got
the trailer for the mandalorian season
three i've been waiting for this so
badly i'm excited john how are you i am
the way yes you are andrew gordon i'm
excited greg how are you
yes this is good
all right ladies and gentlemen
use the force to leave a like that'd be
very much appreciated let's see what's
going on excited to react to the show
right here on the chanel
[Music]
this is the one that you saved
[Music]
you are as its father
[Music]
a clan
of two
now here we go here we go
wow you have removed your helmet
he had to armorer and you are a
mandalorian
no more
yeah goosebumps everywhere
yeah
poketan
your cult holy [ __ ] what
fractured our people
cult fractured our people
where were you then
did you think your dad was the only
[Laughter]
mandalorian at that groove cargo man
look at fly
kelly motto
all right kid
hang on
you ready for an adventure
nipple chills right now nice
i might be like
super biased here but
that was like one of the best star wars
trailers i think i've
pretty damn good it's pretty damn good
that was blending of what has come
before and what is to come what exactly
is going on in mandalore here guys a lot
of conflict i mean because obviously
boca tan her lifelong mission to rule
the lord that seat this is amazing
you saw those other mandalorian did she
was she the one who had the line about
something about a cult disrupting things
yeah about you basically
disrupting things and causing a rift and
he was teaming up with
other mandalores so it was looking like
there there's the potentiality of a
possible civil war in our hands at
mandalore well yeah it seems like this
is going to dive directly into the
remnants of the mandalorian cultures
that are all scattered around and now
yeah maybe because dinjaran is making
such a you know
presence for himself across the galaxy
maybe it's going to reignite some old
tensions and bring to add some of these
timeless political and warring you know
conflicts well mandalore i mean there's
not really much to claim at this point
with mandalore other than your pride
at this point worth a lot of vandalism
has been through the ringer and i know
how much it means to bo katan so you
know obviously at some point in this
show she's probably going to challenge
him to get that freaking dark saber yeah
it seems like there's a much bigger
threat here other than because like this
whole thing
i'm wondering like could it really be a
civil war because they really just have
to fight it out if it's all about the
dark saber because if you get the dark
side where you rule mandalore or is
there actually a bigger threat at hand
and carlos rosita was on stage yeah he
was on stage and he basically according
to the report said that you know you're
going to see a whole new side of moff gt
and you've never seen this guy in a
vulnerable position and you're going to
see new dimensions to him due to that so
i'm curious as to how they're going to
bring him back and recontextualize him
well you saw dr pershing in this trailer
so i wonder if there's something that's
going to happen there which involves
breaking him out i wonder who's holding
him is that what grief is that what
group cargo's doing
is he the one holding off gideon anyway
andrew oh my god you're here no andrew
no i got carried away
there sorry about that andrew that's all
good i'm a good host i'd like to uh no
not to include the guests
that trailer looked i mean visually was
amazing it feels like the budget has
really gone up on this show too i mean
the first two seasons i mean i i felt
like it had a big budget too but just
this is on like a different like the
scope feels a lot bigger the visuals
were impressive not that they weren't in
the first two seasons they were amazing
but the thing that always draws me the
most into it is the relationship between
grogu and jean i mean they are just i
love that you really get that father-son
relationship between the two of them and
that's what just you know and gets me so
invested but the visuals and the the the
action sequences that we get it's just
it looks so incredible i love the
cinematography in this and i mean it
just looks incredible i love the first
two seasons of this show and it i know
i'm one of the rare few likes book of
boba fett but i actually like that show
i thought that was uh cool and i i think
what i love the most about uh what this
show does what john favreau and dave
filoni do with this show is they really
bring a sense of nuance and balance to
like the western side of star wars like
do a good mash of blending between the
two and that's what i love so much about
this show so uh but this trailer was i i
think he put it past one of the best
star wars trailers i've ever seen too
and i loved him just
god dang groku is so damn adorable isn't
he yeah he is absolutely did we see a
baboo frick at one point i thought i did
definitely
freaking there i don't know if it's is
it the actual babu frick or is it there
is only one there is only one there can
only be one baboo frick in this world
but this just looks like such a cool
buildup too because like over the course
of the seasons of the mandalorian and
even the moments he's in boba fett like
there are you know there's called into
question the legitimacy of his whole you
know
being as a mandalorian it seems like
by season three that could be a really
rewarding build because it's not been
like the point but it's been a prominent
detail and now it looks like that is
gonna be like ex like directly
in conflict and directly in the main
part of the story now i mean yeah like
it's as we explored a little bit more in
the mandalorian season two and then with
having mandalorian characters especially
in like the animated series and such
you get the opportunity to see that
there's different ways kind of like
different denominations i would say of
mandalorian religion
and i
i'm very fascinated to see how they'll
do that here or explore that subject
matter and see what comes at odds within
that realm
considering that you're getting all
kinds of mandalorians it's funny like in
book of boba fett when you left off with
mando
it was like uh you can no longer be part
of us because you took your helmet off
and now there's going to be so many men
over here they're gonna call this the
mandalorians not really
because it seems at least in the visual
language like there are some of them out
there who are yeah
like there are some of them out there
who are like uh apt to follow him and
they're obviously the ones who are more
on bogatan's side right so yeah i'd be
curious to see i i doubt that uh the
armorer's you know
decree that he is no longer a
mandalorian is going to fully have stuck
by the time we meet up with him again oh
man looks i wonder what the ultimate big
threat is this time
because because the other two seasons
have been about you know grogu
specifically yeah yeah and or like
that's a that's part of the main
objective is dealing with grogu so
obviously there's going to be something
i played with with dominance with
mandalore but there's got to be some
other massive threat going on as is
there going to be a new story for grogu
other than just like okay i guess we're
powering around forever now and i got to
keep you safe
cool with that storyline too though but
i mean
yeah
i love that visual reference too we got
with the asteroid field from empire
strikes back yeah and i guess you could
say attack of the clones when uh jango
fett is uh being chased by obi-wan
kenobi but that was a cool visual easter
egg a reference
and billy model we're gonna go back to
tattooing maybe we'll probably get your
boba fett reference
yeah we'll probably get a boba fett
cameo in this
he's gonna nod to the camera and then be
gone all right guys well what did you
think about this trailer leave your
thoughts down below i absolutely loved
it um hey subscribe click that bell
there's more to cover we'll talk about
it soon